turquía ya no existe a partir de hoy
mismo este viernes turquía pasa a
llamarse turquía que es lo mismo que
turquía pero en vez de un idioma en
extranjero será en turco así lo ha
confirmado naciones unidas- esta pasada
madrugada cuando ha confirmado que ha
recibido la carta del ministerio de
exteriores turco pidiendo precisamente
que se cambió el nombre oficial
internacional de erc iu en inglés y en
francés o turquía en español y sólo en
turco turquía
este movimiento lleva tratándose en
turquía desde el pasado desde el pasado
diciembre cuando el presidente turco
recep tayyp erdogán explicó que empezaba
a turquía esta iniciativa y viene sobre
todo por un gran motivo y es que en
inglés cherquis significa pavo que es lo
que comen los estadounidenses cuando
celebran uno de los días más populares
en su país que es el día de acción de
gracias además a erc y en inglés
significa algo así como estúpido o tonto
una persona que no tiene mucho interés
en lo que hace ya hago turquía que se
quedó de distanciar completamente en el
gobierno turco asegura que este cambio
es para intentar darle poder a los
turcos para poder que deciden ellos
mismos como quieren que su país sea
llamado internacionalmente sin embargo
pasará lo que les pasa a muchos otros
países que han cambiado el nombre hace
poco como en 2016 o holanda en 2020 a
partir de entonces holanda pasó a
llamarse solamente países bajos y la
república checa- chequia sin embargo
internacionalmente se sigue amando igual
a estos países turquía quiere hacer el
mismo camino veremos en el futuro los
ciudadanos del mundo pasan a llamarle de
turquía turquía turquía o en otros
idiomas a solamente turquía